欢迎大家,大家晚上好,欢迎今天所有来参加咱们这场分享会的小伙伴们,那今天咱们这次的分享会的主题是,期权实战进阶比OpenVLab工具深度解析,那今天晚上呢主要是想带大家伙系统掌握期权交易的核心逻辑与专业工具的实战应用,那今天呢咱们也是邀请了两位好朋友来做分享哈,那一位是OpenVLab的创始人汪洋老师,以及咱们鸿源期货期权研究员深柱老师,那像汪洋老师呢是毕业于北京大学数学学院,
同时深耕海外投行与对冲基金衍生品领域多年
那好朋友深住老师呢是悉尼大学金融硕士
那同样呢也是深入了解期权多种组合以及应用场景
对衍生品呢也有独到的见解
那所以咱们接下来呢我就先把时间交给咱们深住老师
来为我们先分享一些干货吧好不好
哈喽大家好
OKOK
哈喽哈喽大家好
我是红杨期货的深住
然后呢首先我想跟大家说一下
今天的想分享的大概内容有哪些
第一部分就是期权的介绍
第二部分我想带大家看一下
这个期权的传统的提前报价表
然后第三部分呢
就是跟大家讲一下
这个期权的影响因素
然后第四部分呢
是咱们OpenValab的汪总
帮咱们去介绍一下
咱们的强大的功能
然后首先呢
期权的介绍
首先我想在这里简单介绍一下
就是期指的就是未来
权指的就是权利
那期权指的就是未来的权利
期权的交易呢
就意味着买卖的是一个
未来的权利
既然参与买卖
就会有买方和卖方
买方买的就是
未来的权利是权利方
在开仓的时候
是需要付一定的权利金的
卖方则是卖出未来的权利
是义务方
在开仓的时候是收到权利金
而付出的是一笔保证金
是为了保证市场的稳定
和防止未来的违约风险
那买方买的是权利金
就意味着是做多权利金
当权利金上涨的时候
赚取其价差
那最大的损失就是全部的权利金
风险是有限的
而卖方赚取的是权利金下跌的价差
当权利金无限上涨的话
那损失可能就是无限的
但是了解期权的朋友都会知道
卖方的胜率往往是要比买方要高一些的
接下来咱们去聊一聊这个期权的分类
以及背后的逻辑
还有它们的区别
对于标的物未来的预测的方向不同
可以把期权分为两类
就是看涨期权和看跌期权
看涨期权指的就是
预期未来标的物会上涨
看涨期权的买方
就是花费一个权利金
买到一个未来可以以行权价
买入标的资产的权利
而卖方就是卖出的该权利
收到的是权利金
同理看跌期权的买方
买到的就是一个可以
以行权价卖出标的资产的权利
然后简单来说
这四个角色
可以就是这么分类
就是看涨期权的头寸就是看涨
然后看涨期权的卖方就是看不涨
看跌期权的买方的头寸就是看跌
看跌期权的卖方就是看不跌
在震荡行情和行情上涨的时候赚钱
对这个就是我整理的期权的
看涨期权和看跌期权买卖方的本质的逻辑
OK然后接下来我带大家看一下
期权的传统T型报价表
这样就是一个传统的梯形报价表
然后可以看到几个重要信息
第一是标的物
这个标的物不光是有这个
还需要有这个具体的合约
这个具体的合约就关系到
到期日越近的话
那价格就会越低
那这么看的话
远期合约的权利金
肯定是要比近月是要高的
如果作为期权的买方的话
那近月的期权
这个开仓成本就会低一些
然后第二个重要信息呢
就是这个期权的方向
一般左边的是看涨期权
右边呢就是看跌期权
然后中间这一栏
大家看到这个
这一栏就是行权价
就是当做看涨期权的买方
就是买到的以这个价格
买入标的资产的权利
然后最后呢
最重要的就是权利金的价格
就是这里的最新价
看涨期权这边有最新
看跌期权这边有最新
这就是你买方要花费的金额
不管是看涨还是看跌
然后呢这个权利金呢
它的组成部分是有两部分
一个是内在价值
一个是时间价值
内在价值呢就意味着是买方
当下去行权可以直接获得的利润
如果这个利润是正的话呢
那这个期权就是实质期权
就是提行报价当中
这个红色阴影部分的期权
然后看涨是在左边的左上边
看这期权就是在右下边
然后如果这个利润是负的呢
这个买方就不会行权
它的内在价值就是0
就是绿色阴影
这个绿色阴影部分的期权呢
就叫做虚值期权
然后这个内在价值往往是可以计算的
但是时间价值是很难去计算的
因为它的影响因素有很多
它呈现的特点就像阳光下的冰一样
是呈抛物线加速衰减的
越临近到期日的话
这个衰减的速度会越快
然后第三部分呢
我就想分享一下期权的影响因素
主要是五个部分
第一个呢
是标的价格
如果有关注期权的朋友
就不难发现当行情上涨的时候
那看认购期权呢
不管是实值还是虚值期权都会普遍大涨
而认购期权呢
就会普遍大跌
相反行情大跌的时候
看跌期权就会大涨
对所以说期权的整体的行情走势
是基于这个标的物的走势的
所以说在去交易期权之前
你要想好对标的物
未来的一个预测的方向
大概是什么样的
然后呢第二个重要的因素就是时间
刚刚咱也提到
咱们也提到了这个时间价值
是越临近到期日这个价值越低
咱们可以这么理解
就相当于去买保险
你买一个一年期的保险
和买一个十年期的保险
那肯定会十年期的保险要贵一些
因为这个时间越久
可能发生的一些事情
或者状况就会越多
所以更远期的
这个就是时间越长
这个权利金就越大
就越贵
所以说如果
OK不小心碰到
好咱们讲第三个
这个重要的影响因素
就是波动率
有时候在交易当中就会发现
有时候这个资产微涨
但是这个看涨期权和看跌期权的话
都可能会出现下跌
OK那你现在就去看一下
这边这个波动率波动率肯定是会有下降的
因为这个这个波动率越高
就说明他未来发生的状况就会越多
炒作的力度就会越大
这个期权价值就会水涨船高
不管是看涨还是看跌
那当起这当这个波动率越高的时候
那说明这个期权是有波动率溢价的
那这个时候就比较适合去做卖方
当这个波动率比较低
低于这个历史的水平
或者这段时间的一个水平的话
那么就可以适合去做买方去做一些埋伏
目前咱们这个openvlog的这个网站把这个期权的波动率可视化也做的是非常的直观清晰
等下咱们就邀邀请咱们这个创始人汪老师做一个更详细的介绍
ok 那第四个的影响因素呢就是行权价格
就是行权价
在其他影响因素不变的话 认扣期权来说 当行权价越高的话 转向实质期权的可能性就
越小那说明权利金就会比较低
对于认购期权来说
当这个行权价越高的话
就转向实值期权的可能性就比较大
那说这样的话
那个权利金就会比较贵
最后一个就是无风险利率
这个无风险利率通常是被认定为
短期的国债的利率
当这个无风险利率上涨的时候
未来行权价的限值就会降低
这就意味着认购期权的买方
需要准备的行权
准备的这个开仓的资金
准备的行权资金的限制就会变少
那这份权利就会更值钱
因此认购期权是跟这个无风险利率是成正比的
那相反的看接期权跟这个无风险利率
它就是成反比的
对这就是我今天想分享的期权基础的全部内容
总的来说吧
我觉得期权在金融衍生品是一个很不错的工具
可以使用的场景特别多
就比如在抄底摸高的时候
如果担心开仓期货的风险比较大的话
那期权就是一个很好的选择
作为买方就可以用小仓
就是小成本去博一个一个极端行情
那么另外呢
就是按照最近的行情
这个股指这个上证指数啊
还有什么股指啊
都涨得特别疯狂
如果你单边的风险比较大的话
就是你前期有多单
但是会有一些顾虑的话
那也可以也可以用期权做一定的对冲
对 减少一下这个风险敞口
另外呢
期权还有很多的策略组合玩法
我平时也收集了一些
也做了一些整理
如果对期权策略感兴趣的朋友的话
可以私下跟我进行探讨
我今天的分享就到这里了
大家有什么问题吗
可以发到聊天框里
OK 好的
那深住老师我刚听下来
其实就包括刚刚咱们这边有说到
就是最近这个股指上涨
还是比较猛烈的
就是如果是对于目前有持仓的这些小伙伴们
大家又担心说指数下跌造成利润回撤
那用期权来做保护的话
咱们这边有没有什么建议
对最近我有一个特别好的朋友也是在做股指
而且他的仓位就是跟他的总资产占比还不算小
那我就会去反问他一个问题
你现在是担心小幅回撤呢
是现在是担心小幅回撤呢
还是担心大幅回撤呢
如果你是担心小幅回撤和震荡的话
那你就可以选择卖出一个看涨期权
在震荡和就是在不涨的情况下
赚取一部分的权利金
做一定的对冲
那如果你觉得这个震荡和小幅的回撤是可以接受的
但是我就特别担心这个大幅回撤
那OK你就可以选择一些
就是去选择一些波动率较低的一些看跌期权
然后当行情如果有大回撤的话
这个看击期权会有一个很大的一个爆发
那也是可以去对冲一部分的利润回撤
对
然后或者呢
还有一种方法就是看涨领口策略
就是比较适合当下的行情
就是上涨的时候是温和上涨
那又担心这个价格大跌造成的损失
所以说期权是有很多的玩法
如果感兴趣的话
欢迎大家随时联系我
解锁更多的期权策略
现在可以看到吗
OK的可以的可以的
可以的没问题
好的
我可能我就开始介绍一下
我们的网站
我可能着重结合
结合那个咱们最近发生的一些热点吧
比如说
今天的这个五零的大涨
科创五零的大涨
然后我们从这个作为切入点
然后来来讲一讲这个网站
能够具体能够在怎么样帮帮帮到大家
在这个交易当中判断一些
那个关键的一些行情哈
比如说这个是我们现在看到的这个页面
首先是这个
我们的这个是我们的首页
这里如果这点击行情
就可以进入到我们的这个
轻量版的行情
这已经就是我们马上就能看到
我们网站的一个特色
就是我们会把这个标的行情
和这个隐含波动率的行情
能够叠加在一起
有很多人可能第一次看到这个图
我可能稍微解释一下
这个隐含波动率就是通过期权的价格反推的这么一个指标
它反映的是一个期权参与者的这个一个参与意愿
或者说也可以把它解读成就是说
发现当前的这个这个标的标的的一个
不管是上这个继续当前行情的一个趋势吧
今天这个行情就今天的这个走势就很明显的
所以他这个引波在这里的这个图里展示的这个红线
就是这个科创50ETF的这个标的走势
就这个ETF的走势
这里的紫色是这个隐含隐含波动率的走势
很清楚的看到是基本上是一个正相关的关系
就是那个标的如果上涨的话
影波也是也是会上涨
说明他这个现在的这个上涨的这个市市市能是非常强的
等下等下我们也可以会看一些其他的品种
也会出现一些
也会出现一些反向的一些关系
当那个标的上涨
如果影波反而下降的话
那说明这个标的它上涨的趋势是非常弱的
嗯 或者或者说很有可能会出现反转的
我们当前看到这个这个是今天日内的分时图啊
这里还可以就是说 嗯 切换到一个五日线
这个五日线也是蛮有意思的
这里可以看到这个这个是
呃 在这里的话是是是周一的周一的早早上开盘
这里可以看明天也看到一个高开很很高的一个位置
嗯 但当而且当时可以看到这个引波
有一个更大的一个升一个涨幅
说明当时的情绪是非常亢奋的
觉得我的我我我的理解就是说
当时呃
当时有更多的人去会去呃
通过期权去参与这个呃
参与这个这个这个上涨
可能很多人买了这个
特别是很多人买了这个认购期权的
所以他把这个呃
这个引波推向非常高的位置
随着他后来的这个啊
嗯这个标的开始震荡的话
这个引波就开始慢慢的可能
有一个下降的过程
然后直到可能呃这里比较嗯也是经过了一些反复吧
嗯特别是昨天到今天还蛮有意思的
这个盘中一度这个可能嗯继续这个这个这个标的继续有有往上的一个趋势
但是引波其实并没有昨天的话
昨天的话引波其实并没有明显的上涨呢
但是今天的那个特别是但今天可能情况又不太一样了
快接近下午从下午开始
下午一点半左右
标的可能又继续往上
特别是到最后到了两点半的时候
就这个时候引波也引波也开始往上
所以这个现在可能已经比较明确
就是往上的这个这个这个势能是非常非常非常强烈的
我们呃这个这个是一个就是说呃
现在股指是特别是这个科创50位代表的这个这个嗯
这个叫什么叫科技科技股吧
科技股
现在上向向上的势头是非常强烈的
我们可以可以看一下不同的一些例子啊
不同的标题
比如这个是多金硅的一个多金硅的一个走势
多金硅也是最近比较活跃的一个品种啊
我们看这个是他的一个日线图
啊同样的就是说我们这个同时
一个是说展示
呃这个就是他的一个k线图
啊多多金硅的一个k线图
当我们把那个引波叠加以后
可以看到很明显就是说这里
引波已经在
快速的下降了
虽然说这个标的的话
只是在微微的那个回调
但是这块引波已经来到了
就是有一个大幅的下降
我自己就作为一个
我如果站在一个交易者的角度
我会觉得这里就是向下的
这个标的继续向下的一个风险
是非常大的
因为这里可以看到
这个做期权的人
已经就是提前在离场了
他反应在这时候
这个波动波动率
引波的这个快速下降
对
我们这里还可以
就是通过这边侧边蓝
右边的侧边蓝
可以结合我们左边的
这个K线行情
可以看到每天的一个
就是引波的一个变化
你比如说这个
我们这个以多金规为例
现在有三个月可以交易
就三个三个有期权的
合约月份可以交易
它这个都可以每一个月份的话
有这个有一系列行权价
就不同的行权价
这个我这里可以点击这个放大按钮
可以把这个看到这个具体的一些细节
这里我可能简单讲一下
中间这根竖线是说我现在的这个
就是标的的位置
我们在期权里也把它叫平址
平值的位置
现在这根实现是今日的平值
今日收盘的平值
这根虚线是昨日收盘的位置
可以看到就是说
今天相比于昨天
其实
其实标的是略微上涨
上涨了可能上涨了1.48%
但是呢
在上涨的过程当中
就是这一块
就是这块右侧
应该是看涨的
看涨期权为主
右侧的这个
期权的价格
我们是通过这个
我们这里期权的价格是通过引波
就几乎等价于
就是期权的引波
可以看到这里
期权的看涨期权的引波是
相比于
昨日收盘的位置是有明显的下降
所以我的理解是
我站在
还是我站在一个交易者的角度
会把这个把这种现象就解读为
就是上涨
势头呃明显不足
还是说压力还是说还是向下的
呃刚才我们对刚刚才我们又回到
嗯回到刚才的呃讲的这个5050ETF
它这个和多金硅可能就是完全不同的一个
呃一个人一种一呃一种模式
你看这个今日的这个呃标的是大涨了百分之七点几
同时伴随着整个所有的这个
几乎所有行权价的引波都大涨
特别是这个看涨期权这边
这里还能看到就是进一步一些细节
大家如果有兴趣的话
我们等一下可以在这些细节上继续展开
我有可能这里大概讲一讲
这里比如说我们可以看到这个
深红色的柱子是今天的这个
在这个1.55行权价的这个
这个看涨期权的一个增仓变化
这里将近增了
昨天是
对
昨天是7万
昨天收盘是在78084手
然后今天增仓了57,533手
所以有一个大幅的增仓
可以看到大量的人在
在跑步进场
就是买这个认购期权
这个也是说表明
现在市场对这个科创的
这个情绪是非常高涨的
对我们这个我们现在看到的都是
都是就是说通过这个网站
可以很轻很很直观
很方便的就能看到
现在市场的一个
嗯市场的一个全貌
对不管是这个标的本身
还是说呃期权的一个
期权的一个参与
就是对就是你还有
就是说结合这个图本身
嗯也能看到就是
嗯最近的这个
在这个随着标的上涨的
一个过程这个引波也是明显的上涨
有一个明显的一个正向关系
对是说明现在的这个情绪是
非常明确就是往上往上要突破这样
但这个历史上也不总是这样
曾经也发生过就是往下也有可能突破
比如而且还是不久嗯也是
也是不久的不久之前
你看这个就是说
这个这个地方也是引波有一个
非常大的一个上涨
这个是7月4月7号
4月7号当天
有一个
有一个几乎也是一个反向的一个
向下的一个大跌
当时市场对对对继续对继续大跌也是非常恐慌的
当时但是很快这个嗯这个这个这个标的起稳了以后
这个波动率也慢慢降下来了
现在可能又又找到新的方向
就是可能换换了换成向上了的对我们这个是说通过我们我刚才讲的主要是通过我们我们现在网站上能够提供很多啊
这个跟波动率相关的指标啊
能够去感受第一时间能够观察到这个市场的情绪
就是说是否
他不仅会告诉你当前的情绪
而且会告诉你
给你如果仔细观察的话会看到很多
就是说接下来有可能会
就是不同的参与者
他在这个市场当中去
去用自己真金白银去投票
然后去
去去指明一个接下来发展的一个方向
对
然后另一个
我们网站除了就是说
提供各种各样的
跟波动率相关的指标以外
我们现在也是可以方便的模拟
做模拟期权的交易
比如我现在
如果大家特别是对
我觉得就是特别对
就是期权
大家可能大部分
就是对期权不太了解
刚刚入门的人会比较友好
比如我做一个展示
我们比如说大家如果想
交易这个期权的话
可能有时候对
比如自己买卖的一些期权合约本身
它是一个怎么样的一个盈亏分
嗯盈亏可能还不太不太清楚
可能还需要看一些资料啊什么的
才才能够勉强搞懂哈
但我们希望就是说能够提供一个工具
能够让大家方便的就
就几乎没有在几乎没有基础的情况下
就能够方便交易哈
比如说我现在这里点击
我点击了一个
呃呃这是这是点击了一个
看跌期权的
呃买价这里
这里就是说呃我买入了
呃跟系统讲
我买我我我需要买入一手看跌期权
这里就能看到
我的这个买入看跌期权的一个盈亏
嗯比如说这里就很明显
我当我这个标的
呃下跌的时候我这里会出现一个盈利
然后标的上涨的时候我会出现
一个呃亏损
而且能够看到就是随着这个
时间的变化和这个
标的价格的变化我的这个盈亏
的一个相应的变化
我觉得我们现在提供的这个工具是
这个市面上应该是
现在来讲是
唯一的能够做到非常直观的展示
就是在同时展示这个K线行情
和这个期权盈亏展示的这么一个工具
这里可以
这里可以继续添加不同的合约
比如我同时又添加一个买入看涨期权
那这里我就构建了一个买入跨市组合
买入跨市组合的人就是
会他的这个盈亏就是说
当这个标的价格在没有大涨大跌的时候
我可能我要付出一些权利金
或者说时间价值
当我出现了大涨大跌的时候
我才会有一个盈利
这个时候这个我也是说
给大家一个非常直观的一个感受
就是说你当你买入期选的时候
你需要有你需要标的有多大的多大的这个变动之外
你才能够开始盈利
所以你要考虑到就是说
嗯你要付出的这个时间价值
是不是你能够在你承受的范围之内
嗯比如说现在哈
现在如果看到这个影波现在来到非常高的位置
对吗
嗯你现在如果要买入的话
是需要付出比较大的这个成本的
同时哈如果如果嗯
有些人会觉得现在影波特别高哈
或者说期权价格特别贵
你也可以反过来进行卖出
卖出一个跨市组合
你也能够看到
你是在多少
这个标的价格
在多少范围之内
你是处于一个安全的状态
这里就是说
当然这里可以调整不同的合约
你可以卖的宽一点
对吧
这样你的安全边际范围就更大一点
就是方便大家会更直观的去感受
对
这里能够
右边的话可以
就是我们提供的各种各样的功能
可以通过
滑动这个日期
可以看不同日期的
这么一个期权组合的一个变化
对
大概是
这个是一个模拟交易的功能
我们在这个
波动率这块
对
如果大家如果就是想
接下来对
就是对波动率
如果有进一步的关心的话
这里会看到很多
就是跟波动率
然后那个期权持仓的一些细节
都有
都可以发现无穷多的机会
这里面因为有各种
因为期权是一个维度特别
特别高的一个工具
这里在无数
你不管是什么样的
这个方向
你长大涨大跌
小涨小跌
或者不涨不涨不跌
都可以在这里面就构建
适合的一个
适合的一个组合
对我们其实针对这个这里讲的就是说
可以可以通过这里选择你的想要表达的看法
你比如说是你是看涨还是看跌
还是震荡震荡的话就是震荡的话
就是我这里就是迈入迈出一个跨市
就是我觉得这个标的将来不会超过一定范围
对吗
我可能就迈出一个跨市
就是同时迈一个看涨一个看跌
这样去赚取时间价值这样
那反过来就是说
如果我我我希望我看大涨大跌的话
那我可能就是呃去去去去去买去买买买买入一个看
同时买入一个看涨一个看跌这样
他这样就是说
当你呃这个标题出现大幅变动的时候
你才会盈利这样
我们这就是我们刚开始嗯开发的一个页面
后来就是为了大家能够更方便的那个去
有一个就可能都不用自己去去选择组合
可能这里提供了一个更分辨的功能
就是像刚才讲的
就是如果你你自己有一个观点
你脑子中有一个观点的话
你这里可以选择
你是你是这里有666种选择对吗
在大涨大跌不涨不跌和那个小涨小跌这样
他都会根据你选择
比如说这里我选看涨的话
他就会提供看涨期权到背对看涨
到这个卖出看跌这样
还有各种还有各种还有牛市价差这样
他会自动给你匹配一些
就是就这样更方便的匹配一些那个期权策略
这样你就可以直接点进去这样
对比如说这里是一个对他推荐了一个看涨
看涨期权这样都可以直接跳过去
然后你在这个上面再继续进行一个调整
当你选择了一个
这个合约以后
比如说这里是一个
我选择了一个买入看涨
对吗
我想看一下接下来的
我想模拟一下
比如说明天
有可能会发生什么
我这里
我就进行一个保存交易
保存在这个
保存在系统里
然后这个可以来到
我的交易界面这样
这是我
这个第一行的交易
是刚才保存的
现在因为已经售盘了
所以它现在
行情没有变化
显示累计盈亏是零对吧
嗯对但是这是我这可以看到我是这
我是之前保存的这么多历史的交易
这个是在
对这这是之前保存的一些交易
可以看到你可以就是观察他的历史走势
比如说这个是我在8月13号
保存的一个交易
买入了一个框框式
当时是那个
这是一个什么对
一个就是
IH是那个上证50的
这么一个框框式的一个组合
你也可以看到他这个
这个历史的一个盈亏走势这样
都是很
这个做模拟交易也是很方便的
对
对我可能刚才讲
这个是我们如果
这是另外一个页面
是波动率的一个
就是总览页面
它会把所有的标的
这个波动率
曲线图放在一个页面下
这样好
只是方便大家去比较
比如说我这里选择了一个
古纸的一个板块
它会显示这个固植板块下所有标题的这个
现在的波动率曲线图
这里也是可以看到
你看就是这个科创50的这个影波曲线
是相对于昨天是有一个明显上涨
这个是比较刺眼的这么一个变化
而特别又是在这个1.55行权价
有一个大幅的一个增长
你可以看到这个
大家可以看到其他的这个相
你比如说像50ETF300和这个500
它这个引波其实是没有那么大变化的
所以其实今天情绪主要是集中在这个科创50上
对
今天大概是这么一个情况
我们大家也是非常有很多
可能对我了解到很多那个稍微有一点
有一定经验的交易员
可能比较喜欢用这个页面去看一个市场的一个总体的一个情绪
这个页面是用的比较多的
最后我可能讲一讲这个市场页面
就是市场页面
就是整体的一个市场的一个总览
比如说这个在
它分成上上上上半部和下半部
上上半部的位置
主要展示的当日的一个热点
你比如说影波最大上升的品种是什么
今天影波最大上升
可以理解成当前这个势头
趋势最强的品种
你比如说今天很明显
就是几个科创50
科创50ETF
然后加上创业版ETF这样
它不仅那个标的大涨
而且引波也是有大涨
也是大涨
然后反过来引波最大下降
是说那个你可以理解成
是当前这个
当前的趋势出现反转
很有可能出现反转的一些品种
比如今天的这个碳酸锂
他他也有一个很明显的一个下跌
这都是接下来很有可能就是要继续可能要
就是相相相较于前一前面的趋势
之前一段时间的趋势
可能要进行一个反转
对这个也是大家可能比较喜欢看的
每天可能进来可能第一个时间
可能第一时间会先关注一下这个页面
看到就是大概确定当天的一个
那个热点或者说一个反转
出现在哪些品种上
对我可能我尽量
我尽量我先讲到这里
我尽量就是说
不要再去那个在细节上
再讲过于专业的东西
我希望看一下
看一下大家有什么样的问题
我们再进行交流好吧
OK好的
王老师
然后我刚看到评论区
有个小伙伴在说
他说像咱们自定义策略
这个功能模块
未来会增加日历事件条件入场吗
比如像CPI呀
PBI发布日
这些波动率异常的日子
作为条件吗
日历加差
对是的
那个将来也是有可能也是会会加的
我们现在确实是在在在准备这个事情
对大家是那个希望做一些
嗯比如说日历加差
就是不同的月份去做一些组合这样
嗯现在的话只能做单个月份
对确实将来将来回家
ok了解
那我们其他小伙伴如果有问题的话
咱们可以选择在评论区啊
问也可以选择直接上麦问
好来王老师有问题了
就刚刚有小伙伴在问说
请问影波怎么理解呢
影波的话就是
对我可能也是反复
我自己也是这么
我可能做期权也有将近20年的一个经历了
我也是在想这个怎么
对永远有人
对这是怎么样去解释这个事情
影波其实我觉得我现在的
我觉得用一句话解释的话
它影波其实就是期权的价格
就是期权的价格
因为因为不同的行权价的影阁影拨
呃你如果你你你如果去看那个期权的价格本身的话
你是没法比较不同行权价的这个这个期权是谁
嗯谁会相对贵
谁会相对便宜
因为但因为不同的行权价
他就是不同的完全就是不同的合约
但是你确实又又想要去去做做一个比较呢
你就你你就得把它换穿换算成一个
可能有点像
一个均价
你比如说你要去
你要去看一个房子的话
对吧
不同的房子它有
有大有小
但是你不会直接去判断
这个房子的总价
对吧
你肯定是要换算成
它的一个均价会
你再做一个比较会
更合理一些
就我理解是说
影波有点像
这个期权的一个均价
但同时的话
这是一层理解
另一层理解是说
这个也反映
这个市场的情绪
对吧
就是一个你作为一个参与者
你愿意多
你愿意以什么样的价格去
去去去买卖这个期权
你这个因为期权
它有点
它是对未来的一种
那个下注
对吧
你可以
你如果期权高的话
价格高的话
说明大家情绪很高涨
对吧
对如果如果价格很低的话
那说明大家情绪就比较平平淡
这样
它也是反映那个当下的一个情绪
但是我觉得这边最重要的是说
我觉得期权它和很多这个技术指标
就是有根本性区别的一点
是说期权价格是大家对未来的一个期望
它反映是大家对未来的一种预期
它是一个前瞻性的指标
它和绝大多数的技术指标是有本质上的不同的
因为绝大多数的技术指标
它是滞后的
它是基于K线行情所衍生出来的一个指标
你比如说像跟价格
只要是你通过价格衍生出来的
你都是都是之后的
所以在这点上是有本质区别的
OK了解
那其实我有一个问题
汪老师就是像咱们的影波
是直接用BS模型来算吗
还是说用其他的方式
对这个影波现在就是肯定是已经就标准化到
对这个不做特别说明的话
都是都是都是都是以这个BS模型来来来计算的
这应该已经是一个国际惯例了吧
只是说这个BS模型
它可能因为它有很多参数对吧
大家用的参数不一样而已
但是这个模型可能是一个统一的
你比如说像你在取这个标的的时候
你取多少
你是取现货价格
你还是取期货价格
你还是取这个合成期货价格
还有你在取这个到期日的时候
你是用这个交易日
还是用这个自然日
这个对结果会有一些细微的影响
但是影响不大
但是我觉得一般普通
对95%以上的
这个期间交易者
其实是不用特别关心
他这个是用
具体用什么参数来计算的
因为走势最后可能
大致都是很接近的
OK OK 了解了
那汪老师
其实我一直蛮好奇的
就是像咱们这边
做OpenVlog最初的初心是什么
最初是被用户的需求推动的吗
还是说因为咱们自己
也踩过很多的坑
像因为我知道汪老师
自己之前做交易很多年哈
那当年是不是咱们也是算希腊字母算到崩溃
在想着我必须要搞个工具来解放自己
嗯对我我我自己是数学
我一路我我从本科到到后来
嗯到后来读博士
都一路是学的数学专业
其实我对这个嗯数字还是比较
就是接受还是比较自然的
我只我是觉得这个期权确实现在嗯
在市面上大部分的工具
其实是不太
对普通人是不太友好的
或者说特别不友好吧
刚才可能
对我记得刚才就是开
开头的时候
那个深住还展示了一个
现在市面上大
就是一个比较常见的
一个提琴报价的一个
一个图对吧
那个对大部分人看了以后
他可能没有一个直观的概念
我买我买的是一个什么东西
对吧
是为什么不同行权价的
这个合约价格差这么多
对吧
到底我应该买哪一个
大家会会不停的
收到这些问题
我我我可能就是想
嗯,从从根本上解决这个,这个大家的一个这个痛点吧,对,我嗯,希望大家能够就是觉得其实期权没有那么,没有那么复杂,它其实就是一个,就是一个工具,而且是一个很方便的工具,对,能够表达很多不同想法的这么一个工具,对,我们我们我们的初衷就是说,希望给大家提供到这个这样一个工具,能够方便操作,能够把能够交易起来,对,不用说我可能我
教育期权之前还要学很多复杂的期权理论
我还要去推导各种数学模型
这个这个这个我觉得是不用的
对
OK 我刚看到咱们评论区有小伙伴在问问题
汪老师你可以看一下
调做机器人
对 确实有一些
量
确实有一部分这个做量化的这个需求
对 我们后面也会根据大家的那个反馈
如果有足够多的这种需求的话
我们都会去考虑
我们都是会尽量去
就是在合理范围内
都是会尽量快速的去响应
对
我看这位朋友提的是非常具体的
这么一个要求
对
一个需求
OK 好的
那我们其他小伙伴有问题
大家也可以
对 现在大家总结一下
对 我可能也回答一下
确实有相当多的一些朋友
可能希望往程序化的交易去发展
我们可能会就是说
后面陆续会推出一些
跟我们特色
也就是我们跟影波相关的
一些API的一些结构吧
去方便大家去做一些
程序化的一些交易
对
好的
那其实还有一个问题
就是汪老师
像其实我们也知道
目前国内还是有一些
做的还蛮不错的一些期权工具
那你像咱们觉得
像OpenVLAB其实区别于说
市场上目前已经存在的这些工具
那咱们的最大优势
是在哪些方面呢
我们可能是主要在我们的
这个就是这个嗯叫什么这个论这个slogan里面吧
就是说提供最好的图表工具
我们希望我就是我们能够嗯
就在可视化这个是这个这个方向上能够做到最好最好
因为因为我觉得期权是一个特别特别嗯
就维度特别高
如果你这个呃
或者说这个其实是挺看似复杂的一个这么一个工具
你如果没有一个好的一个图形展示的话
对这个普通人是特别不友好的
我们是希望在这个就是往这个
可视化的这个方向上能够做到最好吧
OKOK那像王老师
像咱们您这边平时自己
用PayPal Lab的时候有没有什么
私藏的小技巧可不可以跟我们
分享一下
我可能也没有什么
特别私藏的
如果要说的话
我确实我刚才讲的还真的
就是你比如说我们
我会就是
会特别关注这个每天的
一些大的一些合约的一些
持仓量的一些变化
这个会给我就是
因为这个是一个
他告诉我市场上其他参与者
他的一个
一个
入场或者出场的一个动作
这个会大概率会揭示
接下来有可能会发生一些
发生一些事情
对我可能就是说去会
会比较关注这个
每天的这个一些大额的
一些进场出场的这么一些
期权合约
然后就是说
这是第一点
第二点就是说
我会去看这个
当一个品种出现趋势
或者说
或者说它就是在震荡
对吧
如果是去出现趋势的话
我会去看这个影波
是不是支持这个趋势继续延续
或者说这个影波已经在提前
提前有一个下降
那就说预期这个
这个这个这个这个
这个标题会有一些反转的可能
对
还有这个这个是另
这是第二
这是第二层意思
第三层的话
就是我会去看这个
这个这个影波
是不是在处在一个合理的位置
就是影波是不是
特别便宜或者特别贵
有没有一些买的机会
或者一些卖的机会
我们会从波动率上去看
这个有没有
就我可能因为我自己的
我自己因为多年做这个
跟做事相关的一些工作
我可能对这个波动率的变化
非常敏感
对我们会去从
就是波动率的变化去
一个是说去交易这个波动率变化本身
同时的话
也是说去从这些波动率变化当中去
去叫就破解
这个有可能接下来会发生
就能够提前预判一些
有可能接下来会发生的一些变
一些趋势
对这是我自己作为交易员身份
我可能自己的一些感触
OK感谢感谢汪老师
那其实我还有就是想了解一下
像咱们的用户里面
我觉得应该有不少
应该跟我类似的
就是这种工具依赖者
就是像您这边有没有见过
特别那种脑洞大开的用法
或是有没有像一些
比较特别的用户需求
我们脑洞大开一个
我觉得这个就是
这个一个是说
我能想到的话
第一个就是这个预期波动线
大概给就是能够结合
我的左侧的
比如K线行情
我能够看到接下来这个期权
它能够预示
我大概这个期权
这个标的能够有一个什么样的波动范围
我当我进行买权
不管是买权还是卖权
我大概我心里的一个波动位置是多少
这个是你
如果你不通过期权
你是看不到的
这是第一个
第二个是说
我们就会去做一些
比如说通过
每天我可能去通过反复的去看一些
我在市场总览这个页面
我去看不同品种
有没有一些异动啊
接下来会发生什么
有没有
比如说我会去看这个各个各个板块的一些
因为板块内的它这个品种
它相关性会非常高嘛
所以会特别
就是着重去看这个
以这个板块为基本单位去看
这个有没有一些
在某些品种上有一些
有些人可能已经在进场或者出场
接下来我们会会引发我的一些思考
然后接下来对接下来的操作会进行有一些指导这样
对
我觉得这个对这个这个就是说
这个是说我们就打开了
我觉得对相当一部分
如果他没有接触过期权的人
他是就打开了一扇大门
因为你之前你比如说你们
呃就大部分大家可能做期货或者做股票
他会看这个k线
或者看成交量或者持仓量啊这样
一些传统的技术指标
现在如果结合期权的话
他他会多了一多了一个到两个维度
这样你可以就你之前的经验
他会对你之前的经验进行一个补充
对你这样的话
就是说能够当你
如果你将来你对这个
比如说你通过一些传统的技术指标
得出了一个基本判断的话
你现在可以说通过期权
你可以进行一个进一步的验证
这样会进一步提高你的这个总体的声誉
对
这是我的一个建议
或者我自己亲身的一个感受
OK好的
那我们刚刚有小伙伴在问
未来会开放美股吗
我们
当美股
对对对
我觉得这位
对我们在群里可能
确实我们因为合规问题
短时间内可能开放不了
但是我们也是跟很多朋友在讨论
在探讨这个事
如果要做的话可能也
比如说可能在
那可能应该在境内应该是很难做的
这个有可能将来有可能考虑在香港
可能能做一些类似的工具吧
好的那小伙伴们大家有其他的问题
也都可以就是今天机会比较难得哈
然后咱们创始人直接在这儿给咱们演示
然后呢大家有问题也都可以直接问好吗
因为待会儿差不多9点也要开始夜盘了
所以说大家就抓紧时间好吗
看一下大家是否还有其他的问题
对如果有问题咱就问
如果说没问题的话
那咱们也就可以差不多结束
然后呢大家可以修整一下
然后呢继续今天晚上的征战
好吗
能不能把内测群的那个群号放出来一下
我们对
我觉得主要就是
只要能够登录这个网站都可以
都可以看到很显眼的那个右上角的位置
做的像我们这种
就到跟我们类似的一些
我可能印象中也没有
对
但是在那个
在其他的页面可能有
但是这个在跟波动率曲面相关的确实
我还没有发现
这个活动率对于卖方特别重要
对 所以我们现在群里
我们现在群里有很多
卖方的交易员也在群里
很多 很多
现在还几乎
现在国内的机构几乎都
如果没用的话
基本上也都听说过了
OK 好的
那王老师刚刚咱们提到说
希望大家现在
因为咱们现在还属于是内测阶段
然后也是希望大家可以多多参与进来
那像我想知道
像咱们的这些功能
现在目前都是免费的吗
对都是免费的
但是呢就是希望
这里面希望大家去
这里面会做了
有极少数的功能
比较高级的功能
可能需要一定的积分来解锁
那通过大家可以通过邀请好友来
获得一些积分
然后来解锁一些更高级的功能
但是我们现在几乎去
95%以上的功能都是
都是就是免费开放的
好的好的
不管怎么样
就是说现在现在是
都是免费的
对
而且将来我希望可能也保持免费
但我们可能当然也是在摸索这个
持续发展的这么一个模式
了解了解
对所以说小伙伴们大家想尝试的
待会呢就可以对吧
待会就可以去尝试了
对等一下那个页盘就可以用起来了
刚刚咱们评论区还有一个小伙伴
有一个问题
对对对您可以看一下王老师
对他这个这位朋友应该是比较关心
就是一些
跟就是通过程序化设定条件
然后下单的这么一些功能
对我们现在可能主打的还是一个
就是说通过各种可视化的方式
来展示这个市场的一个基本的
基本的一个就是一个全貌
对一个对对对在交易
在量化交易这块
可能现在还还没有进行一个开发
对但接下来有可能会往那个方向发展
但是我们可能还是会更关注
更多数人的一个需求
来做一个方向上的一个选择
对我们希望还是说
能够尽量的去
让更多的人能够先用起来
OK好的
感谢王老师
来小伙伴们
然后呢
大家看看还没有什么其他问题
对如果还有问题的话
咱们就可以直接问
也可以上麦
也可以打字
那如果说没有问题的话呢
那咱们也都就可以就到这里差不多
因为今天其实时间也相对说
待会儿也就马上快开一盘了
对
好吗
那咱们要不我就稍微总结一下
那非常感谢我们汪老师
我们OpenWebLab创始人汪老师
还有我们今天我们红云期货的研究员
我们的深住老师
两位老师来给我们做了这场
确实是干货满满的分享
大家如果说想要体验
咱们OpenWebLab这些个
确实是非常实用的功能
然后呢
现在呢也都是免费的
大家可以通过咱们的网址
直接去注册
包括也可以直接离校
咱们的内测群
那有什么要求
都可以跟咱们官方去一对一的直接去联系
那包括如果说有些小伙伴呢
是刚刚接触期权
或是对这个比较感兴趣
想要有一些比较全面的电子版的资料
那也可以联系我们前面
我们深住老师
那联系他那边去
领取一份他总结出来非常详细的电子版资料
好不好
对然后呢
然后呢也希望大家可以多多关注Uni
因为后期呢
我还会陆续组织不同的这样的线上分享
那希望小伙伴们呢都能够
就是能够就是了解到不同的
那整个金融的不同板块
包括说平台呀工具什么的
也都希望大家能够就是
减少一些信息差好吗
那非常感谢非常感谢汪老师
也非常感谢我们深住老师
那感谢我们今天所有来参加这次
这次分享会的小伙伴们
好吗那大家有问题的话
稍后的话可以直接去到咱们openvlab的
那个网站也可以直接
或是需要资料也可以联系深住老师
都是可以的好吗那我们今天差不多
就到这里咯然后呢有什么
下来后续的大家也都可以
去跟我联系啊
我都如果说不知道入口在哪儿
我也可以跟大家去讲
好的谢谢
辛苦了
辛苦了大家
拜拜